and this little Goliath F 400 car test
acoustic power
definitely turns heads it's the
brainchild of a big name in German
automotive history
Carl Beauregard he designed a
three-wheeled minivan back in 1924 the
Blitz car had its bed in front of the
driver Krista Bauer says the Goliath F
400 by contrast and it's bed behind the
driver following Beauregard's principle
of load and back power and back the
Goliath had rear-wheel drive it was
marketed as a quick delivery van but the
vehicle is anything but quick it has an
absolute maximum speed of 50 kilometers
per hour and it seems like it takes
forever to reach that
in the 1920s these cheap little 3
wheelers neatly filled a niche in the
market to put Germany small tradesmen on
wheels imitators like tempo rope fix and
standard quickly followed with many vans
of their own but none could fix the
concepts inherent weaknesses christophe
explains of the three wheelers biggest
problem is that it tends to tip over
when taking a curve too fast 30
kilometers per hour was enough to land
it on its side heavy loads and back
helped somewhat also with such a narrow
front the driver could easily misjudge
the width of the rear and end up
literally stuck in traffic
in spite of these minor flaws the
motorized tricycles are a common sight
in the narrow streets of Trentino and
northern Italy
here the piaggio Appa has carried on the
three-wheeler tradition since 1947 it's
hardly any wonder that the freewheel
minivan is so popular south of the Alps
they're ideal for navigating the narrow
alleyways typical of Mediterranean old
towns and orchards and vineyards
with just 12 horsepower the Goliath
manages to climb up two pair to gene a
castle the I know Christophe is
impressed by the two-stroke engine
strength the two cylinder 400 CCS
delivered 12 horsepower and its location
under the seat nicely warms the
occupants behind and it lowers the
center of gravity to minimize the danger
of tipping the competitors weren't
always as clever temple fans yet for
instance at its engine right over the
front wheel which made for rather
adventurous handling the Goliath F 400
weighs in at just five hundred fifty
kilos it's built with only the barest
essentials minimal design for maximum
success over 18,000 F 400s and F 200s
were registered in Germany between 1933
and 1937
the f200 was powered by a six-horse
power single cylinder two-stroke engine
both produced a sound as unforgettable
as it was typical
this Christophe says the little Goliath
F 400 could haul up to 750 kilograms
that's why coal merchants Baker's
tradesmen the farmer and many others
found it so practical and several
variations were available the classic
flatbed is here and the closed panel van
that could serve as a mobile shop with
pulldown shutters or as a livestock
carrier the Goliath swiftly established
itself as the market leader in its class
but even with the sensational success of
his three wheeler kharabagh vard story
did not end well
Christophe says Beauregard should have
heeded the old saying cobbler stick to
your trade the three-wheelers made up
the lion's share of his success but he
wasn't satisfied to stick with a lowly
delivery vans and tried to develop
luxury sedans and even a helicopter but
that cost money and eventually he didn't
have enough to keep up production of his
best-seller when in 1961 the Bremen
Senate refused to vouch for a loan he
urgently needed he filed for bankruptcy
that was the end of Beauregard and the
Goliath around 20,000 for Vaart
employees lost their jobs and one of the
largest bankruptcies in German
automotive history what's left is Karl
Bourgois legacy in nearly every corner
of the world
kristef explains that even a three-wheel
minivans like the Goliath have since
vanished from Germany they can still be
found abroad that thousands and
thousands of tuk tuks all across Asia
for example or the appe and Italy still
in production today he says none of them
would exist without the Goliath it was
the first truly reliable and low-priced
vehicle for German tradesmen and in a
sense the ancestor the VW Golf he has no
doubt that Goliath f 400 is a milestone
in automotive history one question
remains why did walk by and pick the
name of an outsize biblical warrior for
a minivan was it a marketing move or
massive confidence or just wishful
thinking
you